my name is Patrick Nalepa I'm a senior
financial management major here at
Hillsdale College and also a member of
the men's golf team on behalf of the
entire senior class here at Hillsdale
College I'd like to welcome you to
campus today I've been given the great
privilege and honor of introducing one
of the most intelligent men I've ever
met our president dr. Larry Arne dr.
Arne has accomplished much here at the
college but his accomplishments started
many years before that upon graduating
with his Bachelors of Arts degree from
Arkansas State in 1974 with highest
distinction he went on to earn his
master's in government in 1976 upon
completing that he went across the pond
to be the director of research for the
late Sir Martin Gilbert the official
biographer of Winston Churchill upon
returning to the States dr. Arnn
obtained his doctorate and government
from the Claremont Graduate School in
1985 and became president of the
Claremont Institute immediately
following an education and research
institute in southern california there
he served as president for 15 years
before joining us here in Hillsdale
currently dr. Arnn is on the board of
directors for the Heritage Foundation
the Henry salver OD Center of Claremont
McKenna College the Philadelphia society
the intercollegiate studies Institute in
the Claremont Institute dr. Arne has
been widely published on issues of
Public Policy history and political
theory across all forms of publications
and is currently overseeing the
production of seven document volumes
that will complete the official
biography of Winston Churchill
since his time here at the college dr.
Arnn has provided the leadership
necessary to bring Hillsdale into the
top tier of liberal arts school in the
nation he did so by initiating many
academic programs such as the Barney
charter school initiative the Allan P
Kirby jr. center for constitutional
studies and citizenship and the new
Graduate School of statesmanship here on
campus dr. Arne also implemented the
College honor code which signed by each
freshman class is a document that
commits each student to the pursuit of
both the intellectual and moral virtues
that were laid out in the founding of
Hillsdale College this code acts as a
bond between each incoming class and
those who have gone before that being
said please join me in welcoming the
12th president of Hillsdale College the
distinguished dr. Larry Arne Abby sorry
I'm late I was talking to a very smart
senior who's about to go to graduate
school might be a professor here one of
these days so he's more important than
all of you
so this is gonna be the biggest seminar
you'll ever be in I don't have to stand
here do it
I can walk wherever I want to go so this
is gonna be the biggest seminar you'll
ever be in until tomorrow when the
wailing is going to try to frighten you
today that's my job
I want to gain an understanding with you
of why we're going to proceed the way we
do and how we're going to proceed and a
whole lot of questions come up and
you've probably just begun to think
about them but we might as well
anticipate them first of all after this
you're gonna sign an honor code you
haven't signed it yet is that correct
yeah so you got it you know or you don't
get to stay
and nobody's ever raised a question
about that since we published it 910
years ago probably and it's just a
resurrection from something we used to
do in the 19th century and when we're
done today I hope we'll figure out why
we do it and why it works why it's good
and something to do with you what you're
like so the first thing is why do we use
the word honor and why do we use the
word college those are related things
I'm going to argue so who can tell me
what honor means you're not gonna be a
useless freshman class aren't you
there's 385 of you in here yeah that boy
knows what is it
good job chief oh good okay so you would
define it that way does that mean you're
making the claim that that's what it is
yeah okay good so so what other words
did he use good and character those are
big words and what is your name dear who
wrote on the board Rachel we should all
thank Rachel she has an excellent
and what is your name
Quinn what is good yeah
you see how ambitious Quinn is because
this is college now if we use words we
need to know what they mean
so you think good and moral or synonyms
Quinn not quite distinguish them okay
do you see that he just made a series of
assertions that he knows what those
words mean
but we're gonna need all of those words
and the reason is there's something
about people that would be you and me
that makes that word important and that
word important now Clinton has described
that word as meaning qualities in the
human being that are proper and worthy
is that what it is
acquire do you got a long way to go your
name hunter do I like that name although
there's a hunter who's the star for the
San Francisco Giants and the only
dispute I have with the very great
professor Connor is that he thinks
they're good hunter what is it something
you acquire okay the question you're
answering is is honor synonymous with
worthy qualities in the person and your
answer is it's something you acquire it
could actually be not synonymous and be
something you acquire and it could be
synonymous and be something you acquire
right so that might not help us answer
Quinlan's point the first point raised
anybody got another idea
yes sir
own beliefs
a code what's your name John we're done
who John Roman no money halfway between
the Empire and that in the Gypsy so it's
a code by which one upholds one's own
beliefs that good that true Dominic what
stirs about that this is the Provost son
and that means he's subject to any abuse
that I care to heap upon him but that
doesn't really distinguish him you're
all your all's up against that okay so
what is it who gives honor yes
somebody else gives honor okay good so
what that means is Thomas is that your
name Thomas and Rachel are in the bingo
category that's correct right
in other words honor takes more than one
so the military man I met this morning
I'm sorry repeat your name Jamal and how
does it work in the military do you give
yourself honor somebody else give it to
you right you know I own the highest
army civilian medal so I have a medal
that requires them courage and I'm
hoping for an honorary degree that
requires no knowledge so uh so somebody
else gives it to you
the Army is extremely good at that by
the way made me cry and so wow it's a
characteristic of Honor thank you it's a
characteristic of Honor
but it involves more than one is that a
failing in honor it does make it less
self-sufficient doesn't it it means that
you could be awesome and not have any
honor it also means that if other people
are not awesome
you could get honor and not deserve it
yes sir
anyway I think that there are two
intertwined but distinct definitions on
it there are some people I just
explained to move prints recognition of
your merits and there is honor as is
becoming those in how what we can have
with others there they lie between means
the word pride they are connected but
that stings
there you go I believe that what that
means though is that even in your
definition although honorable behavior
might be some absolute standard there's
always a suggestion in it that it
involves what other people think - right
thank you yes ma'am what is your name
Shiloh Wow named after a battle no plays
in the Bible
no it's not
quality of so it would then bind the
people together its deficiency might be
that there's two chances for it to be
false instead of one but the virtue
might be it connects people we won't
talk about that word divine in a minute
and I'll just say we're not there yet
but I'll say as a pre as a prequel to
that that we live in the age where the
whole world is flat
everything is horizontal and we're in
the middle of it and things get elevated
because we values and there's an
antidote that to that among the people
who come to Hillsdale College they think
that everything leads in one step to God
and maybe it doesn't maybe it doesn't
I actually fancy there are many steps so
by introducing that which by the way I
agree with every word you said there's a
whole bunch of argument you got to put
together to get there you're gonna learn
to make them okay so the first thing we
learned then is that honor is something
that brings us together
what about college what does that mean
community partnership right today we
think college means diversity we
actually think this we think University
you know what university means is Latin
word uni means one versa is like vice
versa things turning around right so
it's things turning around one thing
diversity means things turning around
more than one thing and so when the
president of the nearby great University
proclaims in public that the purpose of
the University of Michigan is diversity
duh maybe she ought to change the name
you know the diversity of Michigan and
college means partnership right and so
we have two words that involve
connectedness and we emphasize them here
so the next question is is that right
I'll rephrase it to give a little more
information is there something about us
that makes it necessary when we learn
and grow and understand that term grow
is a value Laden term right do you see
why anybody tell me why yes ma'am
how does it mean that yeah yes ma'am
so I that's true what you said but I
wonder if you understand it yes ma'am
how are we all going to end up dead
alright we're gonna be soil right so
when you say a thing is growing it's
actually true that the end of every
living thing is decay so you right so
you have to distinguish the place where
the growing stops and the decay starts
and you wouldn't be able to do that
without an expression or an
understanding what is it when it's fully
itself went to a funeral when my oldest
friends I've been burying my teachers
and my friends this year signed I'm
getting old and they read one of my
other oldest friends read Mark Anthony
talking about Brutus and Julius Caesar
by Shakespeare whom you probably know
could write he says he was sanguine and
the elements this is a paraphrase were
so mixed up in him
the nature itself could stand up and say
to all the world this was a man but you
see that it's a substantive thing it's a
thing you can see what it is and when
the thing is becoming more like itself
than it is becoming a good one of them
and it is growing and when it becomes
less like itself it is too came at any
age by the way so in the community what
is it about human beings that in a
community where they are to learn
and grow they required to do it together
why is that who knows
yes sir
examples and support thank you is that
it yes sir accountability discipline
examples support and discipline what is
it anybody you got another idea yes sir
so society sets up obligations where we
practice the virtues that's your point
what are the virtues
before we're done we're gonna okay well
could you do those on a desert island
you know if you're going on a sea voyage
I suggest you figure that out before you
go
so yesterday I'm up in the top so we
measure ourselves against each other
those all seem to me true and they also
none of them seems to be the main thing
what are we doing right now and how we
doing it
and when you got woman what happens yeah
you're not alive to the fact that we're
talking right we're talking yes ma'am
what contemplation which is by the way
the silent form of talking talking is
the way we think out loud and I forget
how many earthly creatures can do that
and you know you mentioned the divine
when you think of another being that can
do that
that being is called in one of his
instances of the word talking is the
divine gift it is the respect in which
we are created in the image of God how
do we do it
though I'll use you so what's that that
thing right there with the white t-shirt
the red hair it's a girl
right it's a girl right and the one next
to her with the blonde hair what's that
and yet they're not the same how'd you
know and you know if rape that's a
Rachel I've got two redheads it's very
confusing
would it what is your first name Julia
and Audrey if Julia was the girl Audrey
would not be a girl right and so here's
a weird thing you never see the girl you
actually never see anything ever and do
you see why we can use the term girl or
the term bottle
turn chair we're actually seeing
something that's not physically there
all the time and if we couldn't do that
we would be out without the common nouns
and without the common nouns we couldn't
talk some smart aleck made me a sentence
without a common noun in it there's
always somebody who does yes sir
Ron that's right see there's no noun in
that sentence right do you know what the
sentence means you know how you know how
do you know you know what running is and
running is a noun in fact there are many
ways to run you could run the way our
crime our national beating cross-country
teams run you could run rapidly or you
could run the way I run right and
they're both running and so just like
Julia and Audrey neither of is the girl
know running is the running and yet we
see it inevitably every time and
automatically and we don't even require
to be taught to do it whereas you come
over my house tonight you'll meet our
dogs they're the stupidest dogs in the
county and even if they weren't the
stupidest dogs in the county you would
never teach them the talk and our
talking depends upon our seeing the
common being that makes each thing in a
category itself and so the philosopher
writes the good and being are
convertible terms that means every time
you identify a thing as fitting in a
category described by a common noun you
are recognizing in it the good of that
thing and things that are absent that
good to the extent of the absence are
not anything now that's magical when you
think about it because what it means is
when the philosopher writes in the first
sentence of Nicomachean ethics every
what are the words and Greek the words
are Technic art Pro viruses Chuck choice
method OHS
systematic inquiry I'm forgetting the
fourth aims at some good he's describing
every voluntary human action but also
he's describing the way we talk and that
means that this question of the good is
a question that we share in a different
way than any creature can do our
biological connections among ourselves
and among humans are much closer and
more demanding than other creatures it's
very hard to raise kids and all of
you've got parents and their parents are
up here just we've been like
four-year-old babies yesterday right and
now they're gone and some of you admit
that you miss them and the rest of your
lives right and they miss you very much
I had more girl Megan crying at this
thing that I've ever observed before I
had one fella fifteen minutes ever after
his over and he came up and he hugged me
I thought he's gonna hurl me to the
ground and he said you've just got to
take care of my son and I know that you
will and I said well sir I don't know
him yet but I promise I'm gonna beat the
tar out of him and you know what he said
he said oh that's good
so those connections are really close
and closer than other creatures and one
of the paradoxes of the human being is
that despite the fact that we have need
for each other powerfully through the
family and through biologies and other
kinds of creatures it's also true that
we have complete discretion over it in
this day and age we forget about those
biological connections and their
importance and the family is collapsing
and there's some danger it might be
outlawed
but nevermind it's still the case but
you guys take a long time to grow up and
you're a pain beyond raising dogs and
they're hard you see and yet one of the
reasons is it's sort of in the order of
nature that you get more when you get to
be this age and beyond so those
connections are close but they're
nothing like this connection of talking
we've been in here 30 minutes are we
getting to know each other and all we've
been doing is talking that's the human
gift and you learn through talking and
you need each other just like we need
this conversation I could not speak to
you so well if you did not speak up
however well I can do it whether even if
I do it badly it is still made better by
my finding out what you have to
contribute because first of all it tells
me something about you and second of all
half the time I discover in my classes
the students figure it out say something
to me that teaches me something this
partnership thing is very profound
you're joining it you must take it
seriously it depends on everyone in this
room and everyone in this community and
I assert to you as you will come to see
it depends on that for the rest of your
life
and the rest of all of our lives we have
joined the highest kind of human
association and we can make each other
fully human if we treat it seriously and
we must when you sign the code that's
what you say you're gonna do it means
for example you promise not to come to
class half-asleep
or unprepared and it's gonna be the most
obvious thing in the world when you sit
in the class because it's hard it's
really exciting you know Wednesday today
we were looking at all this pre-opening
stuff and figuring out if we're doing
right because somebody wanted to show a
video here today you know and take part
of my time and that and I of course
immediately format it and on the other
hand that I showed up five minutes late
it was probably only a three minute
video but but you know I'm still able to
get away with things like that you'll
see that Wednesday it'll all be great
because you're gonna meet the people who
can teach and you're gonna meet them in
small groups and you're gonna have
something really great to talk about and
you're gonna go wow I never saw anything
like this before
see so these few days are just a
preparation for that and it really
doesn't matter whether we do a good job
with this or not cuz the rest of us
gonna go great but you have to be worthy
of it for it to go great you must give
yourself to it and to everyone else here
you were made for that deny it if you
will it's still the obvious fact now I
told you that the college has four
purposes our sanctum all of these are
derived from the founding document of
the college the college was founded in
1844 by a bunch of New England preachers
and they were big time patriots several
of them became friends of Abraham
Lincoln they helped to save the Union
they did it in two ways they reasoned
through to help to invent the platform
that Lincoln was elected president on
and they did it so that was just
thinking studying contemplating and then
they did it by all boys and many of the
girls just took off in the war and we
were reduced to a fraction of our size
and they fought very nobly and nobody
made him do that and we don't do
military military training here today
and yet we send more kids to the Marine
Corps than any college in this region 70
colleges we've been told most of them
are larger than us several of them are
more than 10 times larger than
why do they do that so the purposes of
the college founded by these people who
started it are I'm learning we've just
been talking about what that is what are
you and what are you for and what is the
chain of ends above you in which you can
find your fullness you need to know that
people think today that that's not
urgent and that we should get on with
more serious things like training people
how to be welders and dental assistants
but you know if you want to be a good
welder and welder and the dental
assistants or fine things to do although
I'm not partial to the dental assistants
if you want to be a good one of those
you need to be a good human being too
and that means the question comes up
what is that and how should it be given
that it's got choices the second thing
is Christianity this college is strange
about that it's always been deeply
devoted to Christianity and it's never
required a faith statement to attend
there are non-christians here in this
room today and there is welcomed as
everyone else and that's always been
three of the case most people are
Christians and the Christian the college
has purposes of teaching Christian
precepts that's written into the
original that by the way is very like
the first thing to because you know this
high learning stuff come to find out
it's hard and hasn't it just been
exhibited that when you first started
thinking about a thing it's impossible
for everybody to agree because what do
the devil they know they're all just
speculating and also human reason is
weak and that means that we can imagine
a being that reasons perfectly that is
to say when it sees the thing it
understands it's fully and it
understands everything all at once that
would be God in both the classic works
and in the Christian early Christian and
medieval Christian works
and indeed in Farabi and Avicenna and
the great classical Muslim thinkers so
what we do instead is we call from thing
to thing like what you're listening to
me do is help you make connections that
I have already made and you have to have
those connections and they become a
thing of beauty if they do so because
one connects to the next connects to the
next thing you suddenly go along I see
what that is and that means of course
what we can't do is command agreement
all the time and I'll get to that the
third purpose of the college is human
freedom and the institutions that have
proved the best at protecting it which
are named in the beginning of the
articles in language that that echoes
the Declaration of Independence and of
course central hall was dedicated on the
4th of July and what are those
institutions they're easy to see the
first one is representative government
that is to say the government can't do
anything to you unless you tell it it's
ok the government belongs to you and the
second is limited government under
constitutional forms that operate stably
over time and grant and limit power in
ways that are stable the college was
born in loyalty to that and finally good
behavior I want to go back to the
Christian point again because I thought
I left out one thing it's an interesting
thing about Christianity that it's
radically a volitional religion I think
the other great religions are - but in
the Christian Way I'll tell you how it's
so Jesus did something really weird he
declared that he was one God for every
person on earth and that means the
Germans and the English and everybody
and the Chinese and everybody right but
then he also said my kingdom is not of
this world and he didn't set up courts
and enforcement and laws and that means
we're all gonna live in our polity
but we all have a right to worship as we
please
when Jesus says to the Pharisees I think
it was they say who do you pay tribute
to God or Caesar and he says show me a
coin a Denarius in the show even has got
a picture of Caesar on it and he says
render unto Caesar what is Caesar's and
unto God what is God but you know people
missed this point that was an act of
rebellion in the state of Rome at that
time because Caesar claimed the
authority to define what belonged to him
and Jesus is saying as regards the next
world you follow me no matter what but
obey the law long as it doesn't
interfere with that freedom of religion
is implicit in those set of
relationships and the college is
grateful in the first line for the
inestimable blessings that is to say a
gift from God of civil and religious
freedom and intelligent piety that's the
reason I think that they never required
a face statement in the beginning of the
college and why we don't today the
fourth thing is good behavior you'll
notice that we segregate our dormitories
by sex and at some point that will be
inconvenient to you sometimes not very
often but sometimes I'll get arguments
that you know we should really forget
about that and let people stay through
tonight because they do have so much
studying to do and I will look at them
and I'll say to the young men who
typically want to come and make that
argument I'll say do you remember that
I'm a boy too unlike you the father of
four so uh
so we should list these virtues where's
that kid up there who brought him up the
desert island boy there he is he's got
his feet up now yeah so what are the
virtues
ancient I mean pretty much recognize
that food in prudence fortitude
temperance there more so yeah justice
very good so can you see his first wares
footing out on his first paper it's been
pretty much recognized that was good
yeah so the four cardinal virtues are
what's courage you know what courage is
come on yes sir
not just obstacle danger you might get
hurt didn't it weird about our nature
that we're sitting here having this
discussion and we are using terms that
people have been able to use for 3,000
years of recorded history and yet we're
also sitting here inside these bodies
and we're afraid any time it looks like
they might get hurt
cuz they're perishable and that's
poignant when you have an immortal soul
right and so the first great obstacle to
good living is written in the nature of
human beings and that is pain and death
and danger and of course do you all know
the philosopher Jack Handey the Saturday
Night Live philosopher right my family
he's a big favorite in my family one of
my daughters actually quoted him in a
Latin commencement address at the
Hillsdale Academy and he says if you
mean by Carrodus scraping and worming
and begging and crawling then okay mr.
brave man maybe I am a coward right
because what would you do not to be hurt
would you wrong another would you betray
your loyalties because if you would
you're a coward
there's a code in the military I used to
know James Bond Stockdale who won the
Congressional Medal of Honor serving his
country in a powa amp in Vietnam a
barbaric place at that time and he's the
one who helped develop the code
everybody testified to it they're going
to torture you and you're going to break
you must make them torture you first in
that art in that an amazing thing to say
to a bunch of half-starved people it's
okay if you suffer first the result will
be the same and they did that and then
several of them the ones who all won the
big medal must have won medals the ones
who won the big medal what they did is
went beyond that so one guy wanted by
blinking out Morse code while he was
giving his confession that he didn't
been a barbarian and killed civilian and
babies especially on bail and the orders
of the United States of America but he
blinked like that and he said lie lie
lie lie like that right and then you
know what Stockdale did they put him in
a room and cleaned him up every time and
Stockdale didn't ask anybody else to do
this and so he's in that room and
they're trying to make it was a look as
good as they cancelled before they fell
and so what he would do is he would pick
up a chair and he would hammer himself
in the face and just figure himself or
do it on the edge of the table and then
they couldn't put him in front of the
camera and then they would torture him
later for that and then he would do it
again then an honorable thing to do do
you like that story does it make you sit
up a little straighter because see the
reason is you face that trial to all of
us do and you have the same loves he has
and so that thing that threatens you and
the things you love how do you bring
those into a court when it concerns
danger and pain and as you do it through
courage what's the next one
temperance you said what's temperance
that is the correct disposition toward
pleasure you like pleasure
nobody likes pleasure as much as you
guys and I'll tell you why your bodies
are just coming into their own and
they're young and they're fresh and you
can really feel pleasure Wow you know
have any of you boys noticed that the
girls were attractive not saying I have
one time one of my favorite students
here in graduate school now she came to
me that a young man who came to one of
our conferences and behaved himself
improperly to her he touched her not in
the worst possible way but some and she
was uncomfortable and so I said what you
want me to do and she said doctor and
you'll do the right thing I just wanted
you to know so I did call his employer
found out that this was the third
instance of that and he lost his job
over so I was glad I called but of
course people shouldn't treat young
ladies like that and I said to this girl
I said you know you're why I said you
know dear one I call it I call you all
dear and and I said you know I
personally have put my hand on your
shoulder and she said dr. Arnn everybody
knows you're safe would you see if I
weren't what would corrupt me she was a
beautiful girl and you know the greatest
woman I ever met happens to be my wife
the temptation to betray her is written
in the natural human desires you're
seeing a red the lion which in the
wardrobe and the little boy betrays the
siblings to the Wicked Queen for turkish
delight it's just a model of all delight
what would you do for the ultimate
pleasure would you lie would you cheat
the next one is justice if there's
something good thing what would you
rather you have it or somebody else have
it I mean in the abstract right best
room in the dorm if there is one there
probably is icing first place in the
line the last state oh that right well
honor we have an honorable society at
Behrens
together we all commit to it right and
that means who gets honor well justice
is it goes to the one who deserves it
justice in you is paying that honor
impartial even as regards yourself
trying to do fairness by everybody what
was the last virtue of the cardinal
virtues prudence you sin and sometimes
they say prudence and sometimes they say
wisdom what is it in between prudence or
wisdom and the other three sir clothes
but my question was I've been four and
I'm implying that three of them fit in
the group and the fourth one fits in a
different group yes sir oh you well
you've already talked you've already
talked to somebody who hadn't talked you
tell me
close they are virtues of thinking right
where is the other three yes sir that's
good that's true that's a bingo
what's your name Austin when you when
you're in it when we're done you come
over and write your name up here also
somebody over here got a bingo but I
didn't do it properly whoever it is and
was worthy give yourself the justice of
running your name up there okay so so
the intellectual virtues are virtues of
thinking and the moral virtues are
virtues of doing and Austin up there
just said a pregnant thing the two kinds
come together first let's distinguish
them quickly we're gonna finish here in
a minute cuz are we getting tired
we're only little fresh man yeah we're
not tired
so prudence and wisdom are distinguished
there was a hint of it about why wisdom
is not just knowing wisdom is knowing
elevated things ultimate things the way
you get it is you figure them out for a
long time
wisdom accumulates that's why we think
of wise people being old and and each
conquest along the way to think isn't it
is a climb up a mountain and each
footstep that you take and each foothold
that you find is the preparation for the
next step living the life of the mind is
climbing like that and one argument gets
in you I told you I think I said it at
freshman convocation maybe I just only
told your parents but you've got
tomorrow we're gonna dump there
Wednesday we're gonna dump this big old
jigsaw puzzle out on the table and all
the pieces are little
and you won't know where any of them
goes and so you got to put it together
and every time you get a bit put
together it will suggest other bits and
you'll get easier while you go but it's
almost impossible at the beginning
that's one of the many reasons you need
teachers right and wisdom is like that
right as the picture forms it starts to
become coherent and it suggests the
other solutions
that's what wisdom is like what's
prudence like Brutus is the place yes
sir
that's a glib and good but not
exhaustive who are you again John you
can put yourself up there too I want you
to I want you to do it right we'll take
a picture of it and preserve it for all
time and so here's the problem with our
lives right you know that courage and
moderation stuff I said you know
pleasure and pain and here's here's the
difficulty whatever is good these
wisdoms that we learn this assent that
we make the wisdom that actually mostly
deals with things that don't change but
then on the other hand what's life like
it's always lived in circumstances and
there are these pressures and they're
constant is it wrong to kill is it it's
not a yes or no oh that's interesting so
it depends right depends on whether you
want to know I'm always threatening to
kill students and I've hardly ever done
ya know it
what do you wouldn't it be true or to
say it's wrong to kill but circumstances
could make it okay
even good would you say that it's a trap
question but lord once you said you just
gave away the store right because if you
say it depends what does it depend on
when it can save life right so uh
Winston Churchill in 1914 had been
advised that if the Germans landed
toward 1940 if the Germans landed that
they were gonna lose southern England
which means they were going to lose
London which means that the capital
would be gone which means that Wow
how're they gonna get rid of them if
they land cuz they got a much bigger
army than the British maybe they're
gonna conquer the whole country and he
wrote a speech he never had to give it
because they didn't land and the speech
was entitled you can take one with you
now I don't think that the purpose
that's that speech was to spare lives I
think the purpose of that speech was to
say better to die than live with a Nazi
in other words circumstances which are
very unpredictable have a profound on
influence on what it is right to do and
that doesn't and that means that in
action the right thing involves
contemplating or deliberating about cuz
liberation is the form of reasoning that
leads to choices deliberating about
these circumstances as they appear in
light of ultimate ends what is the
prudent thing to do that doesn't mean
the cautious thing to do that means the
right thing to do right here and right
now and you're going to have to make
lots of choices like that students need
courage because at the end it's
overwhelming and you'll you'll think
it's like in every battle it's like this
the enemy comes and the first pattern
you see is that there are these many and
then they're more and then they're more
and then there are more and so the
pattern suggests that there's an
infinite number so of course what you
want to do is panic and run away and
then on the other hand study is like
that too especially your first midterms
yeah because you know you're gonna
figure out after about a week Wow look
at all this
I'll never manage it and I'm used to
making A's forget the Hat right so you
have to put you have to budget your time
and that means by the way you have to
have the courage to possess yourself and
do your best work and even get to sleep
you need and then prudence
that's just choosing what am I gonna
work on in the next hour and a half
given all of the factors and what are
the factors how near are the exams how
far behind a mind what what in mice
current state of physical and mental
productivity can I do best with this
time and you will become more skillful
at that now the development of those
four virtues plus the theological
virtues are the explicit aims of the
college that's why good behavior matters
so I'm gonna close at this point finally
it is a fact I asserted that you are a
kind of thing and you are a made for a
purpose and you have been in it managed
to maneuver
South to a place where you can live an
excellent human life and you get to
start on a different level day after
tomorrow and the glories that can be won
are the highest available to human
beings it takes us all
you can argue anything you want you must
respect the purposes of the institution
why because they are the product of 2500
years of thinking by brilliant people
because they bring us together and
provide a forum for us to work together
and benefit each other and because
hundreds of thousands in fact millions
of people over the life of the college
have sacrificed so that we could have
this privilege we owe each other but the
last point is selfish do you want to be
a happy and good and great human being
are you ambitious enough for that do you
want to take that for yourself and use
it to do good to everybody you know do
you want to be known as wise and just
and brave and moderate do you want to be
a blessing to your children to your
spouse's to your fellow citizens do you
want that that's what you promised to do
and it'll cost you you've got the youth
and the energy and the brains to pay the
cost get up every day ready to go thank
you